hey there guys thanks for tuning in just
a quick one today i'm gonna speak to you
about
um stomach vacuums ab vacuums which work
the transverse um abdominai
and this is a muscle that many people
forget about when they're training their
abs but it's actually instrumental in a
giving you a flat stomach b eliminating
back pain for a lot of people and see
aiding with your correct breathing which
has many other positive effects so let's
look at that in a bit more detail
so basically your abs your midsection
your core
are made up of many muscles there's not
just abs these aren't six muscles this
is the rectus abdomini which is one
sheet of muscle running across the front
of your stomach at the sides you have
internal and external obliques which go
underneath your rib cage
the airish and they're useful for
twisting your body that way and bending
side to side the
rectus abdominal are useful for bending
forwards which is why crunching works
them if it wasn't for these the muscles
in your back such as the erector spinae
would bend you backwards and you'd snap
in half that's why the best ab exercises
which we're going to look at in another
video are ones that don't just involve
doing this short movement which is a
very small range of movement a
crunch actually involve bending further
back or moving your legs more than my
attack crunch for instance
um so those are some muscles in your
core but another very important one is
the transverse abdomini and what this is
is this muscle wraps around
your abs and is used for squeezing in
for bringing your abs in
towards your back
so between the transverse abdominis the
obliques and the erector spinae which
are useful for bending upwards the
opposite of the rectus abdominis useful
for when you're doing deadlifts these
make up nature's weight belt which has
the
combined effect of pulling your stomach
in making it flatter
which is obviously what a lot of people
want but also at the same time
supporting your back and this is one of
the reasons that training these muscles
can help to prevent lower back pain it
gives you a kind of rigid armor around
this area and it's also very important
for
plugging the energy leaks in the kinetic
chain when you're doing exercises like
the press-ups it will make you more
powerful better performance
fewer injuries it's just you need to
train all the muscles around there but
doing just crunches is not going to
target the transverse cell dominant you
need to use different exercises to
target lace plank will do it to an
extent but not hugely so actually the
very best way to train it is just to use
it by bringing in your stomach
like so
when you do this and bring your navel
your belly button
in towards your spine
that is you working your transverse
abdomini and the great thing is you can
do this exercise anywhere
and that's a vacuum to do a proper
vacuum this is what bodybuilders would
use in the golden age of bodybuilding
you um breathe
out
pull up your
your diaphragm
pull your stomach in using the
transverse abdominal and that there you
have an ab vacuum a stomach vacuum which
you know they use for posing but it's
actually also a very good way of
training that muscle giving yourself the
flatter out
so
the combination of the rectus abdomini
to give you the nice six pack which is
all one sheet of muscle divided into six
little segments combined with the
transverse abdominal which is inside you
can't see it but it it pulls your gut in
to give you that flat um stomach
will give you much better core much
better looking abs
i'm working on mine at the moment and
i've noticed
big improvements
so so you want to use those sorts of
exercises the the vacuums and if you
work those into your program you should
notice some improvements there's other
ways you can do it too though one's
called the cat vomit exercise which is
one where you go on all fours and then
just repeat that movement bringing your
navel in towards your spine and then
releasing it and if you repeat that
whilst in this kind of all-force
position that's the kat von exercise as
tim ferriss calls it and again he
recommends using that
in conjunction with the myopathic crunch
and he says that's a great way of
building
a good looking core and i have to say i
generally agree with him you can also i
actually use it whilst doing plank you
can do a plank and then
bring that in but also i like to just do
it whilst i'm doing other exercises like
whilst i'm doing the um the press-ups or
the handstand press-ups i make sure that
i'm consciously tensing this part of my
body bringing in in order to give myself
really rigid you know again there's no
no energy links i'm not swinging around
wobbling all over the place and my form
is much better um
so that's that's very useful
that's another way you can use it now
something i i have heard about regularly
hang on a second
bear with me i'll be right back
yes
what's reading about the transverse
abdominis something i've come across
regularly is the idea of
tying
a piece of string around your stomach
whilst
you've got a slight vacuum on
and the idea behind this is every time
you breathe out oh you feel it push
there so you're holding it in more now
some people say you can use this
technique all day whilst you're at work
once you go through your routine etc and
obviously not using something quite as
noticeable as this maybe a small piece
of strength you can keep it on and
throughout the day you'll be forced to
engage the transverse abdominal eye and
by the end of the day
you'll you know be tired but by the end
of the month you'll have a slimmer
waistline flatter abs that's the idea i
don't i don't personally recommend it
because
in order to breathe properly
you're supposed to breathe from your
stomach you're supposed to breathe by
pushing the stomach out you breathe in
by letting your stomach out
so
what this does is it allows the
diaphragm to relax moving into the
abdominal cavity
and you actually you engage the lower
portion of your lungs and apparently
this can make breathing 13
more um
effective more efficient so you're
taking 13 more oxygen and as a result
you see lower cortisol levels which will
make you feel less stressed and in turn
increase your testosterone and growth
hormone your anabolic hormones um it
will also reduce hypertension make you
more relaxed in your muscles and in
general it's got tons of health benefits
it's far more efficient for running
it'll help you to run further and faster
improving your va 2 max but so you know
having this tied around your waist what
it's going to force you to do is
like not be able to breathe very well
and the thing is most of us already
breathe incorrectly we breathe through
our chests when we should be breathing
through our stomachs if you look at baby
they breathe through their stomachs most
of me for their chest why because we sit
at office desks a lot of the time or sit
in the car
or on the train on the commute and when
we do this our body is collapsed that
makes it very difficult for us to
breathe properly
we're not supposed to sit uh down in
that position as much as we do so to
compensate from our chest and this
becomes habit and so we stop breathing
normally um
you can fix that by focusing on your
breathing but applying a piece of rope
around your stomach because i'm going to
help with that so i don't think that's a
terrible technique i say maybe try using
it occasionally during a workout when
you're trying to remind yourself to
engage your core in your exercises maybe
try it for a little bit maybe you just
want to uh um if you're just bored and
one positive is it does force you to sit
up straighter
which is another important thing posture
actually makes a big difference to your
abs but the difference between my abs
when i'm stood up straight versus
slumped
you know um i don't know like hopefully
hopefully illustrate my point
but yeah so you don't want to tie a
piece of string around yourself all day
i think that's madness
but
interestingly if you do breathe properly
anyways it's a it's an isometric hold
it's just a tense there's no range of
movement you're not going to make much
difference by just holding it in but on
the other hand
if you read correctly so you're letting
your stomach out when you breathe in
like that then you actually pull your
transverse abdomini in in order to
breathe back out you release it
to breathe in and you pull it in
to breathe out you should also be
engaging your chest and your um
into intercostal muscles which are the
ones in between your ribs but that comes
second that's the second part of the
breathing motion
you start in your stomach and it then
expands up to your chest rather than the
other way around
um or rather than not using your stomach
at all
so i can't remember what i was saying
the point is that if you're breathing
out and then breathing in using your
stomach then you're actually
exercising that muscle that's not
getting the attention it normally
deserves every time you put it back in
you're getting a slight tension on it
and you're working it so ideal breathing
will not only improve your mood it will
not only improve your sleep it might
improve your running endurance and your
um
and all these different things it will
only improve your hormone
balance but it will also give you a
small workout on the transverse abdomini
which you can then
further enhance with your workouts where
you're engaging it using things like the
cat vomit exercise
so there you go and um you'll see
all-round benefits by paying attention
to your breathing and this muscle
of course you've got to work all the
muscles in your core and it's also just
as important to make sure you're doing
exercise for your back we have a
tendency the way we train is is it has
no bearing on the way we move most of us
who want to train the muscles on the
front of our body our biceps our pets
our abs and we don't care about the back
so you end up that's another reason you
end up like this that and your office
job so you want to make sure you're
training your whole core and i've put a
link in the description to my website to
an article called ab anatomy this is a
very good pun and that will talk you
through each of the muscles in your core
and your lower spine and i'll tell you
how to work all of them and even your
hips your hip flexors and extensors and
your abductors and abductors they all
play a role in stabilizing this whole
area and making it the way it should be
i'm learning all this stuff right now
i'm diving really deep into it and
integrating it into my training
hopefully you can already see that it's
had some benefits for me and
i'll be continuing my hope over the
course of my videos and i'm going to
share all this information with you here
on my site so if you like what you've
seen today and you found it useful then
please subscribe share like etcetera and
i hope to see you for the next video
thanks for watching and bye